subscribe
ba ba
Counter hali Face Mask service in this
video we will Take a look at the
Translation Task
this
Translation is the Task of translating
the text from One lan strong Another
But you mados ekatektil de Source
Language and output to Translation of de
textile Target  language
before this internship time the manager froze block
score score ranges from Zero to One in
Which one mistranslation Perfect ilmerge
tailor romis you went to throw Shadow Fall
to End up
do not tokens
this Machine Translation deltaset control
pairs of Tekstil a Language Translation
of the text in Another language
This desmundo scanhealth year conversation
Legends acrostic free Language Izban
option is Translate it raining dt100 for
Dutch at bot anthrenus applied spot
this you can't  football Translation made
from your using Dilan is going,
close potest rendon Translate face  erim to send
the internet clasificacion tek de out of
Touch and Hold and translated from
delungo çak Ford Focus Trend onto your
User of language
this for More information about the
Translation Task subscribe six caliph scores